today on our show man lots more Thor who
is tall lords dead
stop man mile it right there plus we're
gonna look at all the latest trailers
that are dropping in time for the
holiday season in the end of the year
right here on Batman Batman
we're back welcome back not bad I'm
Kevin Smith look Bernard a is right man
would have [ __ ] Riggs and Murtaugh of
this [ __ ] with the lethal weapons one
and two and maybe even a little a three
but then we need a Pesci of comic geek
who's that we need if Joe Pesci has to
be it I just wonder just one or two
that's true cuz she was into ya they
[ __ ] you with a drive-thru yeah so we're
like the lethal weapon right but you're
Murtagh your more time and I'm Riggs but
except a less anti-semitic Murtagh
racked and Murtagh looks like I like
Jewish people man like they're awesome
and I made less Australian white guy oh
wait it's a wait I thought I was your
Riggs you would have to be Riggs rig
that's it's true Shane black only writes
Christmas movies Shane black dude before
we dive into anything else man we're
gonna talk about trailers later on in
the show do you see this nice guy's
trail take all my money oh man it's just
like a warm bath of Awesome it looks
like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang - mm-hmm with a
whole different cast like I like shame
but I've always liked Shane black but
man that [ __ ] looks fat Russell Crowe
takes my money all right let's talk
about comic book news and in the world
of comic books nobody reads comic books
anymore yeah movies based on comic books
that's what we're talking today folks
thor ragnarok yeah grab your [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm auditioning for the main theme
Marvel yeah you don't have to get big
inexpensive original sure you could get
Nickelback or if not but I'm willing to
do it Creed in four news they are
they're talking about this is crazy man
they're gettin brassy man they're going
high go to a single some market tell
them what it is Cate Blanchett is
rumoured to be in negotiations to join
Ragnarok that's great that's Galadriel
is gonna be maybe it's not so much she
wasn't [ __ ] Lord of the Ring so she
does Shana
she does this wouldn't be her first time
she was in Indiana Jones for that we
don't talk about oh my lord that's right
that's right she was the that's a
totally different movie to remove the
Russian she was Russian yeah dr. Jones
yes awesome little quite Bettie Page but
that's super click Louise Brooks
cut it took me a second that was yes
true she does genre so maybe it's not
such a big deal yeah I was a holy [ __ ]
she's gonna be in Thor who do you think
she playing I mean it's either like
Valkyrie maybe or The Enchantress
ooh I like enchantress yeah I would say
let her play enchantress yeah I mean let
her play anything [ __ ] let her play Thor
she's a really great actor
there's a lady Thor now so that's true
listen Hemsworth is getting too
expensive we're sure there's Hemsworth
marketplace confusion we don't know what
terms worth we have give me a Blanche is
more Hemsworth the Baldwin's now even
Baldwin is changing his name to hims
with the problem with with you know our
beloved Avengers mmm is that they're
getting priced out of the job yeah
pretty much yeah
it's as each movie happens they get you
know okay can we get a Scarlet Witch in
here [ __ ] gay yeah you guys like to
do two runs real fast because he's dead
his sister's alive and she's Witchiepoo
it's all good
that is why attending Avengers you know
when they show you that shot of like the
Avengers the New Avengers
MMSE or the inexpensive bargain sized
Avengers I'm one of these cats from
Hemsworth vom Robert Downey jr. um you
know I'd be like look go ahead like I
you know I get it like I'd rather keep
playing this part and give it up for the
money I would that's me but I get the
feeling that like Downey's pushing 60
yeah but I still watch it dude watch 75
year-old man I just don't know walk into
the rocky steps like he's a good actor
as he he could like he could be Jarvis
in the suit I mean it just gave him an
Irish lady Jarvis which you know that's
fine but it'd be amazing if he became
Jarvis then the job gets even easier for
Robert Downey jr. though sometimes the
job is literally like sit in this dark
room Hooper on this camera pretend
you're like some [ __ ] around you this
would be easy like coming to this room
where whatever you want stand in front
of am I gonna guide him here say this
[ __ ] you don't have to put on the more
of a wife-beater do you get your show up
I won't charge you the star wars money
for a billion
nice 1.05 billion that's cool
guardians the galaxy once upon a time
there was a rumor that um McConaughey
was in talks to play a character in this
yeah it seems like it fell apart no he
just keeps expanding yes Caruso is now
talking about joining his star Lords
father and come on this is mr. Jack
Burton himself it is a struggle in
Little China he has a place in the
garden is the galaxy world as far as I'm
concerned agree he seems to be what's
the director's name it's not just me
gun he seems to be guns right in guns
with James guns be honest it feels about
right like gun feels somewhat parallel
to Tarantino in a way yeah and he's
absolutely a Tarantino guy so there's a
world in which he could do the funny
he's very like it's not like just taken
straight from big trouble little
challenge but it has all the fun
adventure that because I mean it's its
to me I'm like when I saw this it was
like yes that's bring it I'll watch it
he could still cut it dude I'll watch
there's a snuff film mmm we killed your
father watch the footage but Marvel they
make good movies pretty much can I be
part of the Avengers initiative
Witchiepoo The Avengers because they're
just exceed us maybe magic do you think
cuz honestly the thing I like most about
quicksilver's
yeah nothing he's dead yeah pretty much
like me Quicksilver cannon father for
him is gone what's next stir the okay
Wonder Woman kids who's happening right
now hey before I talk about this put up
that Instagram I'm sorry I'll show you
here all over the place put up that
Instagram picture this with this was in
my this was sent to me by General Mills
like I guess to be like okay spread the
word Fat Boy cereals coming they're
making Batman vs Superman Batman V
Superman is the correct oh so now on the
left is a bowl yes and the right it's a
cowl above this what you can't see
there's another picture is a cape it
came the box set came with a cape so
you're supposed to put on the Cape
yes it's a Star Wars now I'm like I
can't wait for this flick dude and I'm
gonna tell you something inside
information me no dope
yeah a little inside dope can't say how
yes a1 alright can say why whoo I saw
the next Suicide Squad trailer new who's
[ __ ] impressive yeah like remember
how great the first one was even how at
a left-field and you're like holy [ __ ]
who knew the Suicide Squad trailers
gonna be this amazing like hats off to
the [ __ ] marketing people
and trailer I saw Sega Chagas well
anything about it
tell you this bunch got a lot of footage
mmm two minutes of footage song choices
yeah perfect it that's what they're
building a moody like campaign like it's
not as [ __ ] villains fighting no
one's and [ __ ] they're building
something that like people that don't
read comics are interested in I find it
very fascinating what they're doing that
movie so I saw this sega trailer it is
[ __ ] wonderful now is it is it as
dour
as the first one was because I remember
seeing quotes from David a are saying
this movie is more fun than his trailers
made alive I've thought that yes look
it's got a tone mm-hmm but I would say
the second trailers got a lot of like
humor in it okay it's not humor like you
know kind of the simple variety there's
like they'll play out a joke and let
some dialogue go it's not just equip and
stuff son of shots god damned of course
like he's a god like this guy's a great
director man like based on those two
trailers give him whatever he wants
like let him make more DC move lock him
up like gonna be the Brian Kuebler of DC
yes or where the Favreau like back like
he's he's got an eye man like John
[ __ ] shot well yeah it's yeah and
it's coming soon that's the good news
excellent but also coming soon Wonder
Woman's happen there's a shooting a
Wonder Woman pick I know with Chris Pine
a Steve Trevor you ain't kidding my
store right was that lady Thor where is
that Wonder Woman chick holding the
hammer okay she got Thor's hammer silly
Hippolyta yeah who is of course Wonder
Woman's mom in the Wonder Woman stories
and presumably the Wonder Woman movie
they were saying it was gonna be Nicole
Kidman right which would have been bad
ass now they're saying call Kim I can't
do it looks like it might be princess
Buttercup Oh
Oh buttock well that's true it's
princess buttercup Robin right mm-hmm
who's a stunning [ __ ] woman huh I
don't know how old she is she gotta be
as old as me she's gotta be at least 45
yeah um but she's stunning on it no
matter where you see a house of cards
she's great yeah it's great wonderful
actress on that course wonderful actress
period I love one of my favorite movies
of all time is the Hell's Kitchen movie
what's it called grace that fills your
new well [ __ ] remembered excellent
pool mark yes those were our new
directing Robin Wright and Sean Penn
which I believe that's where they met
and Gary Oldman doing a fantastic like
Gary Oldman performance like what's good
flick look it up if you haven't seen it
okay so could be Robin right yeah I'm on
board for that
Yeah right look just show me a wonderful
movie top is playing hipolito all right
fair enough
bye he's got the guns if DC like well
Marvel kind of beat DC to the series
like female lead series thing mmm with
Jessica Jones right and even Carter
before that even and as you could but it
looks like DC might be marbled to stand
alone yeah a female-driven super like
they announced the Captain Marvel movie
but they're shooting the Wonder Woman
movie right now yeah it's gonna happen
in the way it's I think it's like Batman
V Superman squad and then Wonder Woman
so you know it's this huge yeah and not
to mention like she gotta be tell me if
I'm wrong gotta be like the most famous
female severe on the planet who's but
you said this female super it's a it's
leading the question if you're like
superwoman is then you're like Wonder
Woman it's a grab game show yeah but if
you were like name name of female
superhero it's Wonder Woman and then
like distant second is Supergirl maybe
maybe maybe maybe how cuz it's on TV
yeah part of that I mean I guess you can
count Katniss like nowadays Katniss from
the outer you know woman may warrant you
there Catwoman maybe but she's not super
per se
oh yeah so it's not a deep bench yeah
you know it's not like she Hulk
but I would watch that show at a [ __ ]
heartbeat I would if you told me that
there was gonna be a legal procedural
and ABC starring Jessica Walters or
desert get whatever last name is done
Walters but if you told me that that was
where she had to wrestle with her other
nature as the [ __ ] she-hulk and solve
cases in court I'm in charge of a
network you just pitched me [ __ ] you
take all my money you make that [ __ ]
hook by the way if you could tell me
Shulk e's real name tick-tick-tick
tick-tick-tick can help you anybody she
hoax name Jessica Jessica well I mean it
wouldn't be it's not a banner no she's
elated she's cousin yeah is it the last
name not the first name oh so close
sorry you lose all of your money yes you
get to play one more time what's your
what's your barrel I'm a cat lady [ __ ]
it depends it depends on is but if they
lean into the Greek mythology of it then
you do like Ares yeah if they just it's
one woman versus like did you ever see
that Wonder Woman cartoon yeah [ __ ]
good you've never seen it they did it
what about animation did like who was it
it was doing the voice
felicity oh yeah Keri Russell I think
she was the voice of Wonder Woman it's
[ __ ] awesome begins with like a born
she's really good hey that's the movie
yeah make it rain she doesn't have a bad
guy that resonates with an audience now
the other one like that's the one I
think of her like a cheetah yeah you
know or you think of her in collusion
with odds you can take down a Luthor
bizarro or Brainiac or whatever but if I
can go Ares go God of War the
it's been revealed moving combo calm the
white Martians are going to appear on
Supergirl
we knew this we did know this I think
Andrew told us this off-mike he did
didn't say that part of the show no he
did say he said which one bizarro did
there's another news item from heroic
Hollywood
bizarro to appear on Supergirl and they
pulled a quote from Andrew Kreisberg
we've got Toyman coming up we got
bizarro and that was from from our
interview with them if you haven't
listened to the podcast interview with
Andrew Kreisberg it's - part of go
listen to it if you don't listen to this
podcast at all go listen do it anyway
yeah that's pretty fun constructive but
white Martians dude mmm gonna be on
Supergirl and you know we've already met
Jon Jones or Hank Hank Hank Henshaw
David Harewood playing them but they're
doing the white Martian storyline with
white Martians if you know your DC
history they're responsible for the
death of the Green Line we're very much
in so one of the greatest Justice League
stories ever written Grant Morrison
doing the white Martians in the first
like six issues of JLA the reboot white
Martians come and there's this awesome
scene where like Batman and they pose as
superheroes
Batman evades their ship and strings up
some of them never know where those bad
notes and he says I know your secret he
surrounds them with [ __ ] gas and
lights a match because the Martians
don't like far so good go read that JLI
stuff white Martians always [ __ ]
everything up it's all these damn white
I can't wait man I'm in and do a bizarro
on Supergirl huge late like dad since
like remember the old Superboy show like
the you know syndicated one I don't even
know if they did it on Lois and Clark
and I think they did to do it I think
they did on that Superboy show like a
lot of people forget that show but they
were very good Gilbert Godfried was
Mitchell play I don't know I do all
right man that's all the cast in news we
got for you so we should not bad it's
not bad there's a lot of exciting things
happening
look I'll care who they put in these
[ __ ] movies just means these moves
are happening put my mom in Wonder Woman
I'd be like she played a bolide er done
she's a goddess in my world lift that
one he's as pretty as Robin Wright he
lied understand yes you are grace
casting my mom just turned 70 she ain't
watching those happy birthday mom happy
birthday she tuned out in the beginning
about Thor 170 there's no there's things
to do before I leave this world don't
talk about silly books my ankles are
thorn weirdly putting the giggles and
the smiles into my mom I needed you
while I was there visiting there but
cracking rocks I'll ride with you make
it stop send him away
don't get him started you know we got to
talk about give me a single mm-hmm small
bring it in you got to talk about
trailers there's lots and lots of
trailers so I saw a few T's in the
theater and I saw a few of them online
let's go down this
x-men apocalypse I they got my money I'm
gonna see this movie no doubt cuz I've
seen all the extra movies and stuff and
you know the notion of them doing
apocalypse is even like holy [ __ ] I
can't believe we live in that world
that being said on you know the trailer
didn't really do much no it's not like a
good trailer
yeah it's just we're showing you stuff
there was not like there wasn't enough I
don't know it's just I went out when I
was all said and done I was a great I'm
going but and I like seeing what's your
Olivia Munn was excited luck for a blip
yeah and I was and then I went away it's
way more about Sansa as Jean Grey yeah
which I'm fine with but they didn't
didn't do anything in the in the trip
like their big like moment at the end of
is where we put you in the [ __ ] balls
to like who's bald Shh
drop the mic like that was their big
move doesn't my meaning to you oh okay
I'm sorry they're going like okay he's
bald in a wheelchair like didn't feel
like it no it was just here's what we
have so far
assembly just put some music in there
I'm in no it doesn't look bad by any
stretch of imagination the trailer did
nothing to make me go oh I want to see
it even more I was already wanting to
see it yeah what's so inspiring
yeah I'm sure good man he like he
[ __ ] singers good absolutely
after that Star Trek Star Trek beyond
yeah well well here's here's my biggest
problem with it okay you have may be the
most handsome man on the face of the
planet
Idris Elba playing your villain yeah
haha they covered him in [ __ ] makeup
he's at this point like some crazy masky
makeup even see like the lady the white
and black lady around which drives a
zebra lady that would be a lot of good
makeup if they made him that lady but no
he's yeah he's just a makeup dude who
has a couple lines of voice over so the
whole movie he's gonna be makeup dude
yeah yeah I mean that's a way to go look
at man I suppose I'd show his face yeah
it's just I mean just me yeah the
trailer itself I mean look his face
notwithstanding hmm like this the sound
and fury signifying nothing
Wow I mean if I got out of a time
machine and you know from 1970 whatever
the [ __ ] and somebody was like you want
to watch the new Star Trek I'd be like
no it's boring his life and then they
play and I'd be like oh my god Star Trek
is exciting or if you were in the 70s
like I love Star Trek there's a movie
what's it look like is it gonna be like
a bunch of people wrestling with
philosophy and moral quandary dude
kids didn't really like the trek
apparently online simon pegg was talking
about you know look I like the movie but
trailers balls he said it was very
action-packed it was surprising i I find
it consciously to be the marketing
people saying everyone come see this
film it's full of action and fun when
there is there's a lot more I didn't
love it
Simon Says because Simon Says because I
know there is a lot more to the film
there's a lot more story and a lot more
character stuff and a lot more of what I
would call quote-unquote Star Trek stuff
yeah and seeing a movie called Star Trek
you think they've gotta bring in a big
audience the marketing people he's
talking about they gotta bang the drum
to all the Star Trek fans I'd say hang
in there be patient you're getting that
from the mouths of Scotty himself who
said it while he was hanging for my crew
screaming how the lens flavor on this is
not JJ it's Justin Lin it is it's fast
and furious guy so that's why there's
motorcycles it's pretty much that's
where everything's on fire all the time
have they ever I think one of [ __ ]
Star Trek's didn't they drive like ATVs
or something like that yeah one of the
shitty Star Trek's we will talk about
anymore that's true it's like nemesis no
we love spaceships no I tell you right
now motorcycle my cousin Johnny if I
show him this trail he'd be like the run
bikes teleporters for [ __ ] don't ride
a bike look again they got my money down
they had my money before this trailer so
you know I'm the trailer had no effect
in terms of like it's like well I see
the seven o'clock show opening night or
the nine o'clock show opening night
maybe this pushes me to nine maybe I
need a drink first I'd say yes the I
don't know I'm in yeah I was gonna say
something better and I forget what I was
gonna say oh so spoilers but [ __ ]
it's really the enterprise gets racked
yet again they should stop naming ships
enterprise apparently that's the problem
and some people got mad they were like
no Enterprise getting wrecked in the
movie I'm like they did that in Star
Trek 3 get isn't that where they blew up
the enterprise with and they they fly a
Klingon ship for Star Trek for Klingon
bastard killed my son and yes they
[ __ ] fly bird of prey yep so and then
in Star Trek generations they blow up
the enterprise again that's their go-to
move
the enterprise is like a Pinto like the
other trailer was fantastic it's less a
trailer more of a teaser like it's in
the world of harry potter Viton by JK
Rowling over a screenplay yeah it was a
little baby like pamphlet that you put
out somewhere between like the Harry
Potter 6 and air Potter 7 okay so this
is her doing a fan of menace like none
of your favorite care hey kids
remember all the magic in the world we
ain't touchin it we're going to America
which it's blue yeah I think it's like
earlier and in America yeah so it takes
place in like 1902 New York II which all
right if there's Newsies in it then okay
yeah they're gonna dance magic you know
what I saw the trailer for The BFG yes
Spielberg mm-hmm I mean these are not
the same movie by a stretch the
imagination but that one captured my
imagination
like it looks like it's building this
one you know I was like okay I mean you
know I'm not I don't know if unless
you're gonna show me somebody get better
telling me the like alters a Harry
Potter moment and all right Daniel
Radcliffe was spotted on set okay
totally and I don't know how they do it
he's in New York and he's like that
future is magic we can kind of do
whatever let's talk about that I mean
when it's not a trailer but the Harry
Potter news about the play I know it it
so like combining the play that they're
doing right so powering that something
of something I remember the name of it
and he's like 30 or 40 the circle of
death maybe and it's a cool idea she's
like JK Rowling and like yeah for the
stage in the UK just in the West End and
she's like you know how many people are
gonna see it
that's it every many people see it and
the theatre pretty much but they're
casting their Hermione and yeah they
found and I can't call her
african-american because she's British
I'm gonna go black I had to correct a
piece in The Hollywood Reporter where
they wanted to eat yourself
african-american I'm like you can't do
that the American part he's colored she
came out but I saw her make a statement
as if like she didn't know about it's
her project yeah I think she was because
there had been as happens in the
internet a bunch of hoopla and heard
that shitty shitty cuz they always get
shitty in the same way they got shitty
that ruined Hunger Games was played by a
black actress when in the book is
written that she's black yeah look I
never saw his black I would feel
differently about her knowing that she's
glad about that situation you I clearly
you read The Hunger Games book listen
dude I'm a pop ologist [ __ ] a little bit
but okay Jake aid sends out a tweet
saying as described on the text Hermione
has curly hair brown eyes and is really
smart period she's like that's it you
like [ __ ] play the role you know I
know you're smart
you just lost me they're doing now they
did my creepier binding so that's kind
of cool
I mean honestly and like again I'm I'll
go see fantastic beasts hmm maybe not
first weekend they show me a better
trailer unless somebody's like doh
Dumbledore's it gotta connect the world
jungle door yeah which Jude Law doing
you can play younger girl
okay so fantastic but I'm very
interested in that [ __ ] play totally
let's go which the last trailer this
week and then we'll get out of here yeah
well then we got a little PS story and
then we'll get out of here
Independence Day resurgence you see it I
did and I mean that's I wouldn't like
you know if I'm putting my first foot
forward you got a spell bond I remember
these trailers for the first one being a
theater and building oh yeah you sold me
a ticket even though I didn't want to
see that movie with those iconic yeah
just as [ __ ] like the Empire State
Building being covered in shadow and the
White House exploding I'm in and these
cats are just like this time the ships
will only forgive JJ Abrams Becca yeah
name again rooted in manic rolling I'm
rolling some weak yeah man rolling you
gotta come you got to show me something
bigger than a big [ __ ] bigger and they
are absolutely counting on the nostalgia
because they looped in the voiceover
from Jeff Daniels president character so
that's the pretty much like today we
celebrate our Independence Day no don't
bill bill opponent the other Jenna -
who's got the beard yeah the other Jeff
dangles the other white guys who like
the same who's conspicuously absent from
this movie Big Willie yeah Big Willie
Stiles I mean I get you know you don't
need it he's got good shot and
concussion yeah he's got his Oscar movie
did now is there buzz formal there's a
big buzz for him yeah really cuz I
watched half the movies really good in
it but I heard anybody talking about
this flick it doesn't come out yet again
yeah I think it's Christmas
um really so he's like riding high on
Oscar but again the movies good shot I
don't recognize the filmmakers now I'm
sure somebody be like it's this guy
and then we have to go do something this
was a movie though it felt like can't
believe they're releasing a movie
theater it was like an HBO regarding
Henry but not so feel good yeah and at
the end people die it's good though it's
really good but yeah I guess you don't
need I think they went for him I think
there were talks but they probably
couldn't undo as my you know without
love what's his name Jeff Goldblum but
you know yeah the way and what else is
he gonna hack him to yeah yeah it's true
there's a cable guy but you know I don't
know that's that's the one yeah look
I'll be seeing it I just don't know if
I'm gonna rush out soon yeah cuz I'm a
completionist man kind of guy when I was
collecting comics you know I hate this
book you kept collecting it because
that's what you do and finally dude
there's no trailer but you know throw
off that goose Buster's gonna call
ladies those posters are back ladies and
gentlemen
and their girls do you have these
pictures or no they're coming up look at
that I'm sorry I said girls I meant
women in a minimun a sexist they've got
these single-shot posters to check out
like they focus on the iconic
phallic symbols yeah there's the patch
there's the photon the towards the
proton packs there's a little ghost it
was that the reader or is that the cage
that cage that's the cage trap the trap
yeah man it's it's it's all happening
we're seeing it happen right summer I
mean all these ladies a funny pulp I fig
knows how to make a movie hall hey you
know [ __ ] that dude directed is right
a lot of things
bridesmaids might not but I spy which is
totally fun
what did I watch it is Oh [ __ ] the
heat
yeah sandy Bullock picture with with
most mhm
there's a moment where Biff from Back to
the Future
but that actor is like their their
captain or something like that he's got
like this gray hair and he's like
talking to Melissa McCarthy's like do
you know how old I am
he's like really tired and I'm kind of
the beleaguered captain and she's like
like 60 65 38 he's like my son calls me
grandpa so that God made me laugh out
loud oh yeah in Siena MINIX and also
he's doing Ghostbusters for heaven's
sakes come on bring it yeah like it's
back and it trust me
this movie does well there'll be more
ghostbusters they're already planning it
they're already talking about a good or
busted verse there is a Buster verse did
you the other verse that they're talking
about building transformers go Matt's GI
Joe micro knows it's yeah like I don't
know why you do that but that would make
me interested in transformers for the
first time ever and I don't even give a
[ __ ] about GI Joe or the Transformers
but they're like two things then you add
in the micronauts like in the Mary Anne
like right for the credits like because
which are turn we've had big robots the
dog little robot the dog - they might
have sold me a ticket for the perhaps is
that transforms what kids like they
really like the a Batman movie do we
have any small robots that's what it
felt like though like it man made bunny
do we anybody would have anything that
shrinks besides their dick and they're
like yeah man what about the micro notes
Don can we get Channing Tatum back no
you can't have Channing Tatum he's busy
doing sherry and there it is man we gave
you all the news that's fit to print man
as a long ass show we talked about the
casting we talked about all this
wonderful trailers that Ghostbusters and
stuff and yeah that's all you get for
now go home next episode is gonna be our
year-end extravaganza with lists of
things there's gonna be lists yes
that's not even funny and nobody wants
to hear that they were gonna make lists
or top ten list yeah for the year he
made a top 20 for TV that's well I did I
did hit top 10 movies top 10 new shows
and top 10 returning shows you know I
got cast off old [ __ ] cuz the new [ __ ]
it's how I don't have to make choices
I'm gonna if I do a list of top 10 TV
shows its flash episodes 1 through 10
we're actually a probably 10 through 12
through 22
yes season finales like you know you're
not gonna slap it slip in a little
martian manhunter girl that's actually a
really good episode it was a good
episode and it was also like introducing
that character was a real emotional
moment for me man watching him like oh
my god I've always loved this character
and they've even said like wait putting
him in the movies and good he's gone
into the right hands and people that
care yeah so that storyline you know and
I think I think Andrew told us but I was
talking to Jeff John's recently and he
kind of confirmed mmm that came from him
yes standing on the set like wouldn't be
great if he was Marshall Manor it's like
and they were like yeah okay duh too bad
we can't make him Jon Jones why couldn't
you oh it's not the world we live in man
it's amazing
anyway go hopefully you've had a Merry
Christmas we forgot to say that in the
show because we're so self-absorbed for
working [ __ ] and a wonderful Kwanzaa
yeah and if that's a thing you do
festival of lights which nobody does
Hanukkah the song I had to go through to
my yeah but we miss Hanukkah that as
well happy everything and now we just
say happy [ __ ] yes happy Festivus
happy [ __ ] Star Wars man
I'm saying there's my religion and
usually if you wish me happy Star Wars I
would feel the cheer mmm
people got Merry Christmas I'm like nah
that's [ __ ] but if somebody was the
psyche happy Star Wars a happy starburst
retube I guess you don't say that he'd
say no the force be with me hello like
happy Star Wars like even [ __ ] idiot
say may the force be with you ours are
happy life day let's do the song all
right come back next week yeah we'll
talk about the things that were great
this year
always lighting a candle every years in
the darkness you want a [ __ ] 10 [ __ ]
list the [ __ ] out of here we don't do
that we like things here all the things
I've been good mark barnard and this has
been fat man come back next week man
same fat time same fat challenge smart
cat no [ __ ] on for the podcast but here
yes youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
you